So Emily, what did you do this weekend?
>> Well,
I actually had a nice little Saturday.
I decided to hike up
Meru Peak in the Himalayas.
>> Isn't that the hardest
peak to climb in the world?
Its code name is called Shark Fin.
And I'm pretty sure only one team
ever successfully climbed it.
And they trained for it for decades.
>> Yeah,
I don't know anything about that.
I just know it was really tall and
I wanted to climb it.
>> Okay, so did you do any prep before
you went on this expedition of yours?
>> Well, I watched this cool
documentary on the mountain, but
that just served as motivation.
What really prepped me for
the trip was the Google Elevation API.
You see,
I didn't really know what I was getting
into when I decided to climb Meru.
There was this one nagging, yet
seemingly important question
in the back of my mind.
Exactly how tall is this peak?
So to answer that, I turned to
the Google Maps Elevation API.
I simply made a web service request
using the elevation service.
I passed in my lat long and my API key.
And boom, the response told me
that it was over 6500 meters or
21,400 feet tall.
>> Yeah, that's really tall.
That's over four miles of sheer
vertical cliffs to climb.
So, what did you do next?
>> Well, I decided to stay in bed,
order a pizza and
check out Meru Peak on
Google Earth instead.
How was your weekend?
>> It was good.
I stayed home and
watched the movie Dante's Peak.
>> Cool, let's get back to
work on our real estate app.
We had just used geocoding to geolocate
and zoom into an area within the city.
But what if a user doesn't have
a specific area that they care about?
What if they only care that they're
within a reasonable commute
of their office?
Up next, the Distance Matrix API.